Good morning, everyone.
I'm Rosie Martinez,...
...one of the new product development team here at Green & Pleasant.
Let me begin by saying how thrilled we are this morning...
...to be sharing with you the launch of what we believe...
...to be an exceptional new product.
I'm referring, of course, to the long-awaited, best of both worlds vegetarian range.
And please allow me to tell you why I'm so excited.
Like many of you, I travel to Europe every summer.
And I get to try all sorts of local, authentic dishes.
Then I get back home and I wish I could eat them all over again.
Well, this new authentic range, locally sourced dishes...
...from Spain, Portugal and Italy will allow your customers to do just that.
But now, I can hear the sounds of stomachs rumbling...
...so I'll stop and allow you to eat some really great food.
Thank you for listening.
And please come forward and try our exciting new dishes for yourself.